نتوجه الان الى محمود الكن وهذه الشاشه
التفاعليه واستعراض لصور اقمار صناعيه
حصلت عليها الجزيره كذلك لساحل مدينه غزه
وكيفيه تغير تموضع القوات الاسرائيليه في
هذه المناطق اليك محمود نعم ايمان بالفعل
هذه صور الاقمار الصناعيه ستظهر نمطا
جديدا من المناورات العسكريه اذا ما
شاهدنا هنا هذا هو كامل قطاع مدينه غزه
سنشاهد هنا بهذا اللون الاصفر هي
مناطق كانت سواتر ترابيه تتواجد فيها
الاليات العسكريه خلال ايام التوغل التي
تجاوزت نحو 105 ايام لكن المناطق الحمراء
هي مناطق توجد فيها اليات عسكريه هنا
نشاهد في شمال قطاع في شمال مدينه غزه
وجنوب مدينه غزه نشاهد كما كان اللواء
فايز دويري يتحدث منذ قليل تغيرا في انماط
التو العسكري تتحول المناورات على ما يبدو
حسب الاقمار الصناعيه الى نوع من العمليات
السريعه عدد اليات اصغر كيف يكون ذلك هنا
شمال مدينه غزه اذا ما اقتربنا قليلا هذه
السواتر الترابيه سابقا كانت توجد فيها
اليات عسكريه بعدد اكبر من العدد الذي
نشاهده هنا لكن الاليات على الاقل التي
اظهرتها صور الاقمار الصناعيه لساحل مدينه
غزه في ال من يناير هنا تظهر تموضع
الاليات في هذه النقطه في هذا المربع
الاحمر ام نحاول عد حوالي 30 او 40 اليه
في هذه النقطه في السابق كانت توجد اعداد
اكبر بكثير تتجمع في عده مناطق الامر ذاته
ينطبق على جنوب مدينه غزه اذا ما توجهنا
اليه هنا سنشاهد نفس البصمه
وجود المناطق والسواتر الترابيه الخاليه
على طول شارع الرشيد بالمناسبه بالقرب من
الميناء وكنا نلاحظ في صور كتائب
القسام رؤيه البحر بالتالي يمكننا ايضا
الحديث ان هذه الاشتباكات كانت قريبه من
المناطق الساحليه وهنا سنشاهد باللون
الاحمر وجود تجمع
للاليات جنوب حي الزيتون جنوب الشارع رقم
10 هذا هو الشارع رقم
10 هنا وشمال وادي غزه بالتالي تقريبا
نتحدث عن مستوطنه نتساريم سابقا في هذه
النقطه
ايضا المربعات الصفراء هنا تشير الى فراغ
موجود او سواتر ترابيه فارغه ليس فيها عدد
اكبر من الاليات الان صور الاقمار
الصناعيه هذه اذا سنقتل قليلا هذه هي صور
لتمركز الاليات وال
ربما الخزانات التي تزودها سواء بالوقود
او الصهاريج او غيرها نلاحظ هذه المناطق
ايضا خاريه اذا ما عدنا الى النمط الاوسع
هنا مره اخرى سنشاهد ان صور الاقمار
الصناعيه هذه تركزت على حوالي كيلومتر
ونصف الكيلومتر هذا هو ما تعرضه صور
الاقمار الصناعيه في هذه المنطقه فقط
ولذلك يوجد قراءات لهذا النمط لهذا النوع
من المناورات
وسنشاهد المزيد معك ايمان ومع اللواء فايز
الدويري عن تحليل هذه الصور للاقمار
الصناعيه